I wrote this one paper called
democratizing rescue we were sort of
um myself under a court author um Luke
Kemp um were analyzing the way that
Global risk studies are currently
looking methodologically even at the
problem of global risk and I think
um they're missing a bunch of things by
just pocketing into
um a climate change risk or biological
risk right rather than looking at it
from uh more sort of mundane literature
that is looking at hazards
vulnerabilities exposures they're
breaking it down in different ways and
one of the things that you notice quite
quickly is that a bunch of types of
risks sort of fall through the cracks if
you just allocate them according to an
expected value or these pockets of
themes
um and one of them are the sort of
latent a potentially epistemic risks
right so that is essentially the way
that we're making decisions together
um not being up up to the task of the
types of decisions and the type of
expertise that is needed for that
decision to rebuild the movement after
the fall of Sam bankman freed effective
altruists need to embrace a humbler more
decentralized Approach at least
according to Carla Zoe Crema
Carla is a doctoral student at the
University of Oxford in the department
of psychology with funding from the
future of humanity Institute
she studied at eth Zurich and LMU in
Munich and was a winter scholar at the
center of the governance of AI also an
Affiliated researcher at the center for
the study of existential risk at the
University of Cambridge and a research
scholar at the future of humanity
Institute in Oxford and also a visitor
to the leather Hume center of the future
of intelligence in Cambridge
now Carla has just published an article
in Vox titled how effective altruists
ignored risk I'm going to read out the
introduction now I'm quoting
little did Carla know at the time that
Sam bankman freed a prodigy and major
funder of the effective altruist
community
who claimed he wanted to donate billions
of dollars a year was engaged in making
extraordinarily risky trading bets on
behalf of others with an astonishing and
potentially criminal lack of corporate
controls
it seems that effective altruists who
well at least according to chat GPT aim
to do the most good possible based on a
careful analysis of the evidence are
also comfortable with a kind of
recklessness and willful blindness that
made Carla's pompous claims seem even
more fitting than she had wished them to
be
by that Autumn investigations revealed
that bankman Freed's company assets his
trustworthiness and his skills had all
been wildly overestimated as his trading
firms filed for bankruptcy and he was
arrested on criminal charges his Empire
now alleged to have been built on money
laundering and securities fraud had
allowed him to become one of the top
players in the philanthropic and
political donations Arena
The Disappearance of his funds and his
Fall From Grace leaves behind a gaping
hole in the budget and brand of
effective altruism color said that
people joked online that her warnings
had aged like a fine wine and her tweets
about effective altruism were akin to
visions of a 16th century saint
less flattering comments she said
pointed out that her assessment was not
specific enough to be passed as Divine
prophecy and she agreed for anyone
watching effective altruism becoming
corporatized over the last years
The Washington Post fittingly called it
altruism Inc uh Carla said in her
article
um they would have noticed them becoming
more increasingly insular confidence and
ignorant
Carla said that anyone would expect Doom
to lurk in the shadows when institutions
turn stale color went on she said that
in Halloween this past year she was
hanging out with a few of her effective
altruist friends half ingest someone
declared that the best effect of
altruism Halloween costume would clearly
be a crypto crash and everyone laughed
wholeheartedly most of them didn't know
what they were dealing with or what was
coming
now Carla calls this epistemic risk the
risk that stems from ignorance and
obliviousness the catastrophe that could
have been avoided the damage that could
have been abated by simply knowing more
epistemic risks Carla said contribute
ubiquitously to our lives we risk
missing the bus if we don't know the
time we risk infecting Granny if we
don't know we're carrying a virus
Carla said that epistemic risk Is Why We
Fight coordinated disinformation
campaigns and is the reason countries
spy on each other
she went on still
is it a bit ironic for effective
altruists to have chosen ignorance over
due diligence here are the people who
smugly at times Carlos said advocated
for precaution and preparedness who made
it their Obsession to think about tail
risks and who doggedly tried to predict
the future with mathematical precision
and yet here they were sharing a bed
with a gambler against whom it was
apparently easy to find allegations of
shady conduct the affiliation was a
gamble that ended up putting their
beloved brand and philosophy at the risk
of Extinction itself
Carla went on she said how exactly did
well-intentioned studious young people
once more set out to fix the world only
to come back with dirty hands now unlike
others Carla doesn't believe that
long-termism which is the EA label for
caring about the future which by the way
particularly drove bankman Freed's
donations or a too vigorous attachment
to utilitarianism is the root of their
miscalculations
a post-mortem of the marriage between
crypto and EA holds much more
generalizable lessons
now for one the approach of doing good
by relying on individuals with good
intentions a key pillar of effective
altruism appears in Carla's eyes to be
ever more flawed
the collapse of FTX is a Vindication of
the view that institutions not
individuals must shoulder the job of
keeping excessive risk-taking at Bay
according to Carla
uh she closed the introduction by saying
institutional designs must Shepherd safe
Collective risk-taking and help navigate
decision making under uncertainty
so to finish off summarizing Carla's
article on effective altruism
um I mean first of all I should clarify
these are Carla's words not mine
uh I'm I don't really have any skin in
the game of effective altruism I mean if
anything my intuition tells me to be
skeptical of it it seems to have an air
of elitism and grandiosity
it also has cult-like qualities that
make me uneasy
nevertheless I think there are some very
interesting topics to explore here in
terms of governance the effect of AI and
other Technologies and of course the
power of information in society
Carla said I'm quoting
she's sympathetic to the type of greed
that drives us Beyond wanting to be good
to instead be certain that we are good
most of us have it in us she suspects
the uncertainty over being good is a
heavy burden to carry but a highly
effective way to reduce the
psychological dissonance of this
uncertainty is to minimize your exposure
to counter evidence which is another way
of saying that you don't hang out with
people that EAS call
non-aligned in air quotes
so she thinks that homogeneity is the
price they pay to escape the discomfort
of an uncertain moral landscape the
metrics used by effective altruists are
imperfect at best and small errors can
quickly snowball into huge consequences
furthermore she said the shift to
long-termism recently in the community
and expected value calculations have
further muddled the impact of effective
altruism as the direction and goal posts
of impact keep changing while the speed
of the progress Remains the Same
it's not the long-termism that should be
blamed for Effective altruism's failure
but the lack of effort to create an
environment where mistakes can be made
safely color said that we need
institutions to take the lead in
managing the uncertainty and not expect
individuals to be perfect bayesians
she said that for the next decade
effective altruists should take an
Institutional turn
she said that we need to determine the
best mechanisms to assess and choose
risk policies and figure out what
procedures and Technologies can
aggregate biases and accurately
incorporate uncertainty she went on that
the establishment of permanent citizen
assemblies in Brussels and the use of
machine learning to find policies that
people can agree on are already underway
EA groups however have the opportunity
to test these policies more rapidly
Carla said that we need to research and
find the procedures that best elicit
experts deliberate predict and vote EA
should be the lab to amass empirical
evidence behind what truly works
Carla concluded that in order to make EA
members take responsibility for their
decisions open philanthropy should fund
a new organization to research on
epistemic mechanism design
despite the fears of bureaucratization
failures and wasted resources are
inevitable epistemic collaboration is
not a nice to have according to Carla
Crema
it's essential
this is a clip from Professor Luciano
floridi from Oxford University I spoke
with him last week by the way I
published that episode
similarly to Carla he thinks that the
real problem here isn't super
intelligence or even AI alignment per se
it's more of a classical problem of
governance and having the right
institutions the right policies having
more friction between the legal
landscape and the technology landscape
and it should not be left to individuals
to make the right decisions
you can devalue human skills you can
remove human responsibility you can
reduce human control erode human
self-determination The Rock who thoughts
that their little draw or water
was nothing
18 years later has a big hole in it
because drop after drop after drop the
drop Will shape the stone will shape the
Rock and I'm a bit worried that here
human nature no we philosophers we know
something about human nature we'll kick
in
uh we're lazy
we're also very malleable
and we are easily convinced to do this
or that
so we need to be a little bit more
careful exposing this very fragile
malleable entity to a very robust
quite silly very efficient
very successful
technology there will probably tend to
inadvertently change the nature of that
fragile entity this is something that I
would like to be a little bit more
concerned about not Terminator
the challenge therefore is how you
govern all this but governance is a
matter of design
ing the right policies so that the
incentives and the disincent centers are
in the right place there are no
loopholes people tend to do more the
right thing than bad thing so all of a
sudden we are shifting all this into
socio-political issues
as a matter of design design the kind of
society we want remember what's the
human project here that we want to
implement
also joining us this evening is Igor
Craft Truck he is a researcher and PhD
student at the Lions laboratory at epfl
his current research focuses on
generative models and reinforcement
learning for combinatorial domains in
particular their application to
integrated circuit design
on the humanities side he's particularly
interested in the interaction of
specific algorithm systems and their
biases with humans and Society at large
in particular he wants to contribute to
the mechanisms of accountability that
ensure benefits of AI systems are not
monopolized or abused and improve our
understanding of governance structures
in general
somewhere in between is the subject of
algorithmic mechanism design and game
theoretical analysis of existing politio
economic systems now I have had
privileged access to a position paper
that Igor is in the business of writing
he's uh he's as far as I can tell he's
almost finished writing it but it's
called why I do not worry about AGI risk
and he said that he's unhappy with the
current state of the discussion about
AGI risk that he Encounters in the
effective altruism community and its
adjacent circles on the first page of
his paper he gives an outline
he says that he thinks alignment is
either a non-problem or identical with
the principal agent social choice and
good corporate governance problems in
politics
he said that he doesn't agree that the
risks posed by losing control of human
level or Beyond AGI are plausible or
indeed large enough to pose an
existential risk he goes on that AI risk
is first and foremost a political
problem he doesn't think technical work
on technical AI safety which is to say
interpretability algorithmic fairness
and robustness Etc can help reduce AI
risks without political pressures which
themselves are risky things due to
regulatory capture and finally he says
that he doesn't think that we are at all
close to human level AGI and human level
AGI will if at all be achieved in
incremental individually well understood
steps
days no Terminator coming there is no
gods in the sky deciding for us there's
nobody but Humanity responsibility for
what we're going to do with this
technology and anyone disagrees
I hope is just naive and doesn't have an
agenda
I had a conversation with konolihi back
in December he is one of the co-founders
of a life at Ai and the CEO of
conjecture and he has some very
interesting opinions on AGI and scale
and Alignment uh this is Connor so a lot
of um by the way you know the the the
the rationalists in philosophy so the
different types of different type of
rationalists like Thomas Nagel and the
name Chomsky we spoke to Chomsky he said
that many things in the world are just
beyond our cognitive Horizon he gives
the example of the prime number maze uh
you know which rats can't solve because
rats just don't have the cognitive
ability to do that no one understands
economics
right and Chomsky says that physicists
are meter readers and um he he cites
physics as being almost like this very
reductionist view of a much more complex
reality and we just kind of take
observables and and we create
intelligible theories to understand the
world that we live in so isn't isn't
that cognitive Horizon going to stop us
from building interpretable AI if we in
one shot build systems that are so far
beyond a carnitive horizon you can't
understand them and then we turn them on
we die
obviously if we
can we build systems that are 0.5 or 1.5
cognitive Horizons and we just develop
much much better theories to understand
them now that's more that's a more
interesting question and if we have a
1.5 system can we use it to build a 2.5
system and if we have a 2.5 system can
we use that to build a five system
and if we have a five system you need to
understand the 10 system I don't have an
answer to this question but it doesn't
seem obviously impossible to me it seems
obviously
probably impossible that if you just get
a thousand X AGI draws from the sky
you're screwed you can't understand this
thing it's you will never understand
this thing we will never ever understand
this thing and if we turn it on that's
it and we'll game over but if we build a
much more that's why that's why I'm
focusing on this like we get to build
the AI
this so this is a common conversation to
have with people where people are like
wow Conor why aren't you like happy
about like scaling laws it makes like
our Intel like predictable and like no
no it doesn't at all it's it's we don't
know how to predict how smart AIS are
this is a big problem while the Align
problem is hard it's people sometimes
will be like oh it's fine we'll just
wait until it's like just below danger
and then we'll stop and I'm like first
of all LOL imagined corporations just
stopping B how do you know you're just
one step away from the bad thing before
it's already too late how would you know
and sometimes people like you know hand
waves something's on the scaling laws
I'm like okay at which loss does it
become super intelligent
and please show me the number like no of
course not that's very silly it's the
ability to predict how
powerful system will be is dependent not
only on the agent you're studying but
also on its environment so you also have
to have a very very strong theory about
the environment it's interacting with
and because the environment is the
universe and we don't have super strong
predictive theories of the entire
universe we can't predict this kind of
stuff and this is why this is at the
core of why I think this is hard I think
if we could all agree to just like
and slow the down let's just like
go only like teeny micro steps until
we've like developed as much Theory as
humanly possible and then we take one
more micro step and then we develop as
much Theory as humanly possible and we
take one more microstep yeah I think
we'd be fine probably maybe not you know
maybe one of those microsteps still
kills us but it's like possible but like
currently we're not even trying like
currently we're just like let's just
make as big a steps as possible as often
and as fast as possible and just see
what happens a little
yeah it's really interesting because um
in a way you're you're like a mystery to
me because you are very bullish and and
accepted I mean you're worried about the
future but you're very accepting of the
the technology Revolution that that's
going to happen over the next few years
and I guess like my skepticism is having
just done a show on sale for example I
know you don't agree with so but he
makes an argument that agency and
intentionality are very important and he
actually thinks biology is is required
but when I spoke to Pedro Domingo's
about this he said no Tim that's
ridiculous it's like you know you you
have a grain of sand and it turns into a
pearl so you have the starting
conditions and I guess you might argue
that AI becomes really dangerous when
you have this reflexivity so now it's
going to the internet it can compile
code it can run programs it can interact
it can improve itself and all the rest
of it so I guess like the question to
you is what do you think are the most
dangerous steps or maybe you don't want
to talk about that you don't want to
talk about this yeah I can imagine if I
knew how to build a dangerous AGI I
would not tell you
and presumably you do
no comment
this is a snippet of a conversation I
had with Ethan Caballero at nurits in
December or so last year I think it's
interesting to compare Ethan's opinion
uh he is a an AGI scaling maximalist
with uh eco's opinion but but do you
think there's something that you like
because we're talking about scaling
bottlenecks is that an intrinsic thing
in systems and
like I mean there's a notion of like you
know there's an exponential an
exponential goes like it goes it's an
X-Men show Forever Until it hits the
like physical bottleneck and that turns
into a sigmoid it's like there's that
notion of bottleneck like if like you
know you scale so far and that you're
like even scaling further than like the
fastest future supercomputers yeah then
like you you'll hit then you've hit like
you know the the bottleneck of compete
on the x-axis okay so so what do you
think the the bottlenecks will be in in
the world that we live in
um we're talking like kind of where
you're like kind of extrapolating
timelines like epic AI Jaya kotra stuff
yeah um
I mean basically the current narrative
is like for the next 10 to 20 okay for
text it's like
it's basically compute's gonna be the
bottleneck until like mid 2020s or mid
30s 30s yeah for video like compute's
going to be the bottleneck at least
until the 2040s but and then at that
point it's going to switch to data being
the bottleneck okay okay then that's
just for the capabilities part for the
alignment part it gets more complicated
because they're like you're bottlenecked
by like how fast can humans like send
their preference data to like the
machine to like you know do like Ro from
Human feedback or whatever yeah yeah I
mean I agree that's not the fastest path
to ikgi but if you're just saying like
oh why should we believe it it could be
simple like the one that actually
already happened was like a cartoon is
just simple at the right level of
attraction well but presumably you do
think that it would also be possible to
construct an AGI you know using some
kind of a higher level system let's say
a cognitive architecture but why would
we not want to do that just it has more
scaling lives that's this or or like it
might have better steering laws but like
we'll have scale into it yeah doing the
dumb thing before we have figured out
the cognitive thing
anyway folks I really hope you enjoy the
discussion this evening remember to
subscribe and give us a rating on your
podcast app
enjoy
um one of the things that I find in that
space is just that there's a lot of
memes that are not particularly helpful
in actually dealing with the the real
questions that we ought to be dealing
with
um so maybe it helps a little bit to
think about what risk even is right it's
sort of a set of probabilities over a
set of outcomes and that are not
preferred for some reason
um and then when you're thinking about
trying to minimize risk uh rarely you
can think about trying to get it to zero
you're always thinking about shifting
that distribution away from particular
set of outcomes that you do not favor
and then you immediately are asking that
question of well who gets to shift that
risk away from what set of outcomes that
are not preferred by what kind of people
right so there's immediately this
question of a political dimension in
influencing risk because it is about
controlling a set of outcomes
and as soon as you are taking that frame
and you're putting that into the context
of AI
um you can ask the question of well how
do you actually control a set of
outcomes well you can make
um have a better understanding of how to
actually influence particular outcomes
um so that is uh trying to gain a more
fine-grained understanding of the
particular procedures that lead to
political outcomes you can get the
possibility of having better predictions
about how your actions influence certain
outcomes you can already see right a lot
of algorithmic tools will be very very
useful in this and a lot of control over
outcomes will come from measuring right
uh gaining access to data so simply um
aggregating more information again lots
of AI tools are going to be useful there
um and gaining more predictive control
by it and so
this this intersection I think of
control and algorithmic procedures
um immediately pushes you into this
question of the political Dimension or
risk and the political dimension of AI
and that is something that I think in
alignment or in AI safety and generally
in the global risk domain is not
discussed very often
as soon as some people get to set the
particular procedures by which outcomes
are being controlled and probabilities
are shifted
um you are asking the question of who
has the power to set those particular
controls and that tends to be a small
set of people that may or may not have
preferences over outcomes that are
actually matched to the preferences of
the people that are experiencing the
outcomes of these events
um and that leads me to ask the question
of is AI alignment or Safety Not Just
a few computer scientists suddenly
discovering that actually there's a big
literature in the humanities and have
been dealing with this question of how
do we align people in a multi-agent
setting right whether that is Citizens
with their government or people that are
considered consumers with companies or
citizens with each other
um in a setting where they disagree
about what outcomes are favorable which
kinds of risks are worth taking and
which ones are not worth taking this is
very much a question about values right
and about politics
and that is I think a really big meme
that hasn't really seeped through the
debate is that this is a very very old
question an old set of questions that
are now being rediscovered under a
different type of language with
different labels
um and that is a little bit concerning
in the sense that
there is a huge literature that one can
just look at it's a huge set of experts
in political Theory and so on that
obviously have a lot to say about these
these issues but because we label it
alignment or so on it is considered a
technical question and a question about
how do we code the particular answers
um in you know an actual computer code
could I just have one comeback on that
so I'm interested to talk about or to
Define what kind of risk or what kind of
quantity we're dealing with here
Heidegger spoke about the risk of
Technology itself which is to say this
intermediary between us and ontological
reality and how it goes two ways it
deranges us
and uh you know people like Luciano
floridi have spoken about the dangers of
information and I guess what I'm saying
is that one lens is quite a common one
which is that there's a pernicious kind
of almost like a climate change of
society and then we can get into the
discussion about governance and so on
but some folks talk about AI risk in
terms of runaway intelligence like
something which is an immediate
existential risk so which of those two
are you talking about
so when you take this control version of
AR risk or this control perspective
then I think the most likely outcome is
not this AGI super intelligence type
scenario but what you can imagine is
simply the kind of Dynamics or control
that we currently see in institutions on
steroids so what we're doing here
similar to what we see with normal laws
you're standardizing a set of
preferences of a small set of people
usually across a whole range of contexts
that apparently could be treated with
the same set of procedures right the
same laws the same algorithm and there's
an assumption made that this particular
set of procedures that you specify wants
is applicable to all of those different
contexts and sometimes that works
sometimes that doesn't right but what it
does is certainly to exert the control
of the first specification of that
procedure by that set of people
um onto the rest of people that are
being you know
under that procedure being being treated
in that way
um and so the me you know the most
likely outcome here is a sort of
calcification I think of the kind of uh
institutions that we see and the
problems that come with those
institutions right so what are the
governance failures that we see at the
moment you don't imagine well what would
happen if all of those would be codified
in
in code to code right the the kind of
switches
um so really the kinds of rest that I
usually talked about in the surveillance
right or authoritarian regimes using uh
these set of tools to their end these
are the much more likely outcomes I
think
um
and and certainly the ones that we
should be more concerned about these
lock-in scenarios than these AGI single
run away scenarios but there's a lot to
be said about this this idea of the G
and the AI um which I have a lot of
problems with and and the general Meme
here
um but but yeah that I think is the the
most likely outcome that we ought to
focus on wonderful um Igor let's bring
it over to you so um first of all uh
there's this wonderful term by Luciano
fluoridi which it calls a single
planetarium which is there's also the
atheist that's about AI atheists so
there are two extreme views so what's
your position on that and what levers
can we pull
what is the term singularity in
atheism's context so um singular
singularitarians are people who think
that the singularity is close and
there's going to be runaway super
intelligence and the atheists spell AI
are people who think that AI is
completely useless and will never amount
to anything so that's a spectrum where
do you exist on that Spectrum uh so I
like one take who was comforted by
Charles Strauss but the singularity
happened in the 1970s when the internet
went online and we're like already post
Singularity but like the original
meaning of Singularity was you can't
predict things after after this one and
and then uh people kind of use this as
their new like apocalypse where things
will be revealed and at this point like
history finally ends and so like the me
like if you take this concept seriously
and you don't just look at it in this
historical context of people predicting
the end of the world for thousands of
years basically then one point where you
could play so it would be where we
really went from being able to exchange
Legends of data Maybe in a city to
everywhere on the planet and there's
like one meaningful point to put that
there
um
if you take maybe a more common version
of answering this is that
I don't think there's ever gonna be like
this radical change and this disruption
because if you look close enough at any
disruption you usually see you'll have a
small increments that like this was
coming a long time ago everybody
remembers the iPhone suddenly appearing
and then a couple of years later it was
everywhere but they didn't see like the
three or four Falls starts or like that
came before they kind of led the way
before it was finally ready and in the
same way like I don't think AI would
ever be like completely
um it would be useless or I'm not saying
that we might never have something that
has like a human level of intelligence I
just think at that point it will be so
well understood what that really means
that we will not really look at it as
like this momentous shift this is going
to be like oh look this was obviously
that was going to come we all have
adapted to it or already as we already
keep doing because the the way we talk
about AI is the same way we talked about
software before which is the same way we
talked we talked about industrialization
this goes through history whenever
there's there's like a new technology
coming and so I'm probably closer to the
a The Atheist part but not completely
saying that it's worthless just but it
would be a very boring like time when
the AI actually arrives
on that a tiny bit because there is a
digital divide now that there are
um you know thousands of exabytes of
data it's increasing exponentially we
have a digital footprint which is kind
of diverging from our true selves and
our children will leave very different
lives to us uh they'll be so hopelessly
enmeshed in technology and don't you see
that as quite a significant Transit not
really because like before the invention
of a printing press like books were
something that you might own one and you
have Twitter to pay like more money than
you would need to feed a family for
decades for and now books are like a a
commodity that is also like a momentous
change that occurred like the amount of
data that we we work through now like a
lot of this data is just big because we
have the ability to process it and we
have a sensors to process it so like
it's not like we are drowning as like as
a Society in in in data and that like it
has completely changed our our
capabilities just that we have a
capability of processing data so we go
to the limit of this capability of
processing and data and like this uh as
we have built up over like centuries of
development more and more capabilities
of processing uh data so have we built
up a variety of collecting and it's
storing it and working with it and there
is a new type of literacy that is
required to actually engage in inverse
like it used to be that you were fine if
you couldn't read and then that became
mandatory and then it was fine to not
really know anything about computers and
now that is mandatory like if you want
to participate and be like a fully
um kind of emancipated human in these
societies and in the same way it's gonna
probably be a requirement to enable
people to own their own data own their
own you call it like a digital footprint
and have a type of sovereignty and the
things lost like the gdpr are like a
response that is coming like just in
time but again these are the same types
of process answers that have been
happening in similar ways through the
history and we are acting as if it is a
big momentous thing because it's always
nice to live at the end of History where
like this is the final thing we need to
solve and then either Utopia disaster
but actually usually like things are
very boring and we will like have lots
of lawsuits and lots of Regulation lots
of political debates but like there's no
magic and if you if you go into this
with his mindset of like oh this is this
is different you kind of implicitly
hyping up the technology so like the
companies selling the technology to deal
with this data they love that like it's
a really good marketing thing but if you
look at it like in a sober not like
cynical way but not a
um like salesperson away like yes it
will change everything just like the
hundreds of times this has happened
before okay
um so so Carla um
there was that film The Social dilemma
uh which spoke about the um the
derangement of our attention then we
have you know um the Advent of Google
and and marketing and so on and of
course I mean even Chomsky and his
manufacturing consent he spoke about the
deranging forces of markets but
um I I would argue that there is
something different now when we have
digital simulator of of ourselves in the
world
um we have things like um privacy
problems um appropriation problems and
and so on so
um I mean would you would you agree that
that it really is quite quite a change
yes one thing we should take note of and
I fully agree that you are here is that
um you know this is a set of statistical
tools that we package under one term
which we call AI and that's an extremely
good way to
um create a bunch of hype a bunch of the
risk is precisely coming from
tools that are not quite ready for a
particular context to be applied because
that context is too complicated too
complex and the tool is just not able to
capture all of that
um but they are being applied by
companies by governments
um because the promise of them those
tools actually you know capturing the
complexity of that particular context
was hyped up under the term of AI right
and a lot of people have made this this
comment that um
you know we we ought to go back to
talking about it as a set of statistical
tools and take the magic out of it in
Parts also because I think you're
completely right to raise
um all of these real issues of privacy
of the attention economy but none of
this is Magic and I think this is
exactly what what ego is portraying
really well here is that if you take
away this layer of this is an
existential vest that is this runaway
technology that will run towards us
there's nothing we can do then you by
default disallow every citizen and every
politically minded person who will have
an opinion on what they consider to be
um their rights on privacy how they want
to deal with their attention and how
they want it to be affected or how they
want to vote
um you will not allow them to be part of
that conversation and I think when
you're considering the kind of narrative
around a alignment and safety this is
weird combination of on the one hand
saying
um the kind of world that we imagine to
be good in the future
is exactly the world that depends on an
AGI type Singleton and the kind of
technologies that we only get by solving
intelligence and at the same time we
um are needing to build the thing that
we're most scared right that object that
is creating this existential risk which
is already a strange way of thinking
about risk the the only way why they can
consider this to be the biggest thing
the biggest risk to work on because
there's a sort of neat agent
um like story to be told of how you get
from the current world to one that is
ruled by this Overlord uh that that
kills everyone takes control over
everyone usually a very abstract and
implausible story to tell
um but it's it's the only way in which
you can actually get to this concept of
existential risk where everyone dies
from you know one single event which is
actually not how risk happens usually in
the World it happens much more via the
kind of thing that you mentioned right
now where you have these systemic
interacting problems that are
interfacing very hard to disentangle but
they create particular scenarios in
which then something blows up usually it
doesn't blow up to the extent that
everyone dies right but AI is the only
way to tell that story and then to say
the expected value of working on that
thing is the most important thing
turns out also to be the thing we need
to create our Utopia and there's this
strange dichotomy and ego I mentioned
this to me at one point I think
um that if you take them seriously for
that belief they wouldn't really be
acting in this way as they do now what
they're doing now in AI alignment on is
to very much run with the theory of we
need to be at the Forefront of that
development in open Ai and deep mind and
so on in order to have a say about where
this technology goes if you really
thought that technology would kill
everyone and would be that existential
wouldn't you at least argue for
moratorium wouldn't you at least try and
set up a campaign to inform citizens
about how terrible this is and make them
do an uprising
um there's so many other ways of dealing
with this issue but I think this points
towards a bit of an ideological again
like a political
um motivation behind why we need to
support these set of Technologies
interesting um ego I mean I think to it
to a certain extent this is a matter of
gradient and um I I agree with you uh
Carla that maybe it's more abstract and
analogous to climate change rather than
something that's going to run away but
you could still argue though that
technology in some sense is enslaving us
and none of us here are techno Luddite
with we like technology but then if it
is pernicious and Abstract then we get
into consequentialism essentially
because we're talking about possible
trajectories into the future and and
various interventions so um what's your
take
okay so first I have to say that like I
need to State out even if we don't have
time to go into it in the spot because
it's that the risk scenarios that lead
to like the technology running away are
built on assumptions in assumptions and
assumptions so there's like so many
assumptions in there that you you
basically leave any claim of doing like
forecasting and you're just doing like
in my opinion bad science fiction and we
can make get to it every time
the next thing answers with the ladder
it's get a bad rep that they will not
enter technology the latter lights were
highly skilled Artisans who felt that
like they were not
um like meaningfully compensated and
accounted for in the technological air
shift and were basically organizing to
have a voice in that transition and then
as usually in in history things like the
people who had more power crushed
Uprising and there's novice meme we have
of like the ladder it's being just
anti-air technology which is not the
same thing as saying hey like we don't
think it's a good thing that we worked
very hard and we have all of these
skills and we have like also helped you
maybe perfect these looms and now we're
being completely marginalized by them
with no accountants for us and like we
are people we we have rights and we
assert these rights
[Music]
um
so let us just want to let it and we're
not the actual question that you asked
which was
um like are we being a safe by
technology is like know if there is like
an enslaving part or anything with our
agency it is also like like these
emerging systems that like our social
systems that we build
um Charles Strauss has a wonderful
keynote of the communication Congress I
think three years ago where he makes the
argument that if there's one finger in
segments it is the fact that we have
like advertising or operationalized to
kind of nudge us into making our
consumption and political decisions
according to the whims of whoever pays
for them and basically being
like push into a form of probabilistic
like violent uh duress by this you could
maybe make it make it make this point
but even that would be a bit too
dramatizing it's too it's kind of too
impressive
what it really is is that technology is
an amplifier technology allows you to
amplify your abilities and capabilities
and as our technology gets better it
amplifies both the good and the bad so
what we talk about with privacy
surveillance all of the other things
these were already problems like 100
years ago the governments were opening
letters and and putting like very
primitive listening devices in in
people's houses you know like doing like
the gramophone thing against the wall
and as technology gets better these
overreaches of government that we needs
are like political legal solution to
deal with gets more urgent the fact that
companies simply have until gdpr
not the right but like no reason not to
collect data
it's not a technological problem it is a
pre-existing problem Amplified by
technology that you can't deal with with
more technology you need to deal with it
on the social political and legal level
okay are there emergent scale effects
though because let's trace the
difference between the invasion of your
privacy when someone opens your letter
and what happens at the emergent
macroscopic scale when it's
industrialized
that's that's a very big question but
I'm not sure I'm qualified to answer
like in one go but like what would you
like to like specifically go on to end
like what changes would like like what
do you think is like one change that you
see because I I having a problem to like
make a big statement about this in an
open way well first of all we we love
big stuff I mean we're called straight
talk so we love big statements and um
and just use your intuition but no um I
guess what I'm what I'm looking for is
there's a real analogy here with the
concept of scaling we talk about the
scaling of artificial intelligence we
talk about the scaling of of the
societal um impacts let's use the
industrialization of misinformation as
an example with large language models is
there an epistemic difference when it
happens at such a broad scale across the
side I personally don't think so in in
the sense that like it is already a
problem if uh you can
get a small group of people into into
believing things that are bad for them
uh with a lot of effort it's just that
um it will only affect these people
Society Society Lodge doesn't care uh
basically
and it might even be useful if it is
like a one-sided thing where like if you
are
um part of like like let's say you
Rupert Murdoch you you think it's lovely
to be to be able to like spread a
misinformation or maybe alsocial
information I don't want to get sued
because with murder is scary but you
know like I'm very poor there's nothing
to gain here
um but like that like just uh like
causing problems for the the less
well-educated the less privileged in in
a sense and the ones are being targeted
is kind of something that doesn't affect
society so it can afford to ignore it
but now if you have in theory let's
assume this is actually the case because
that's already like another one of these
like implicit framing so it's like yes
this technology enables this let's
assume this allows it to like to
industrialize spear phishing or or
misinformation and that wasn't possible
before
um then the only change that this has is
now it actually becomes a problem for
the people that were previously able to
ignore this and the solutions remain the
same the solutions are that that you
Empower people to critically engage with
media I'm from Germany so we have this
humboldtian ideal of Education that you
are really given the ability to engage
fully as a political human actor if you
are given access to the cognitive and uh
like like
gives you and that is expensive it used
to be the privilege of a few gentlemen
in their castles like this room a bit
and now it becomes kind of for a stable
society that keeps producing like the
the goods that we like and keeps the
economy going it becomes kind of
necessary to empower
more people to do this type of critical
judgment and you can't get the way of
saying ah it's okay they don't need it
because they will be working like media
labor jobs will be done that valorize in
our society as much as the only change I
re I really see in this if and that's
that is like before we get to the point
that this was possible before like we
had like a misinformation campaigns by
like National actors but also by just
well well funded
um uh political and and uh like
religious organizations before that we
had to deal with and by definition these
were human level intelligent because
they were humans paid through the
misinformation so I don't think there's
a big difference there because an ego
you said before that there's an
accelerating polarization basically you
said it is accelerating the negative and
the positive and the digital divide in
in general speaks to the um the
fractionation of society and the folks
who can do new types of of of jobs in
the market for example so um
is is this a significant
um thing to worry about yeah I I do
actually disagree I think it's um
it's it's huge I think the ability to
predict when these potential tipping
points or so happen just because you're
scaling up a capability that we have had
before right if you're looking at the
second world war with the propaganda
campaigns that were running there via
radio
um sure technology but obviously not at
the same scale or the same type that we
are capable of now
um when these arise in what context it's
very very hard to predict and often you
know you can even analyze those things
only a couple of years later
um when you have seen a new effect in
the first place and then you have to go
through the uh the data that you have
from you know three years ago and then
have a court case about it and so on so
our ability to really uh analyze this um
what we now that space of sort of
epistemic coordination epistemic Warfare
hybrid Warfare
um that sort of information campaigns
essentially right
one thing there's various um seminars
here in Oxford that are trying to wrap
their heads around how do we even talk
about these new potential challenges
that come with these new epistemic
infrastructures
um that can be used harmfully and I
don't think we're fully there yet
there's a lot of terms floating around
and again we're having the problem of
people you know throwing sexy terms out
and not really doing a lot of the
intellectual work so I actually I really
think we need to do a bit more work
there one of the reasons is that I think
that is precisely I wrote this one paper
called democratizing rescue we were sort
of
um myself under a co-author um Luke Kemp
um were analyzing the way that Global
risk studies are currently looking
methodologically even at the problem of
global risk and I think
um they're missing a bunch of things by
just pocketing into
um a climate change risk or a biological
risk right rather than looking at it
from uh more sort of mundane literature
that is looking at hazards
vulnerabilities exposures they're
breaking it down in different ways and
one of the things that you notice quite
quickly is that a bunch of types of
risks sort of fall through the cracks if
you just allocate them according to an
expected value or these pockets of
themes
um and one of them are the sort of
latent a potentially epistemic risks
right so that is essentially the way
that we're making decisions together
um not being up to the task of the types
of decisions and the type of expertise
that is needed for that decision to
actually come to the Forefront of that
decision making moment
um if we don't have that across lots of
different institutions then we're making
the same replicable mistake all the time
right and of course these new
technologies are sets of statistical
tools and applications
um they come into that question of how
we actually are going to make decisions
and one of the super interesting areas
here is we can start both in the
positive and the negative side
um aggregate actual expertise for a
specific task in a way that is very very
different than we've done before at the
moment decisions are made by you know
people that are selected for some boards
some company CEO some people in
government selected by you know
procedures that at best we call
Democratic which is usually uh every
four years you get to you know have one
road that is binary kind of like a
polling we have much much better tools
now the whole literature on the
participatory democracy deliberative
democracy shows that actually the
solution to the the questions that
you're raising
um is not to poll people in a moment uh
where they've just formed an opinion but
to put them in a particular procedure
where whether or not you're an expert
you can deal with information that is
obviously you know it has to be accurate
in a way that actually processes it such
that everyone changes their opinion so
these deliberative uh Democratic methods
they the literature shows are quite good
at making people change their mind and
come to a conclusion which
um most people then end up agreeing with
so there's lots of different ways of
doing this but now you can think about
circumventing a lot of the problems that
we're seeing in the misinformation space
um by having these pockets of
deliberations between citizens that are
essentially protected in in this
particular Way by having a procedure
that is very trustworthy and you can
also think about scaling that with the
kind of techniques that are now possible
with AI tools right so we don't have to
do it just with 100 people in a room
very expensive to organize we see this
now in Brussels for example they have an
ongoing citizen assembly these are great
experiments but they're obviously very
local and in person there's definitely a
place for them but obviously you can
think about what do we do with a whole
platform of of social media platforms
that can actually be a space where
people can deliberate at scale and we
can now use NLP to seep through that
information right there's a lot of
possibilities here and one risk clearly
is also not using those tools for good
or Miss supplying them in a space where
actually it shouldn't be applied yet so
the transparency of those algorithms to
the citizens that are using the platform
has to be you know front and center with
that debate absolutely and as um can I
type a quick follow-up with Carlo and
then we'll move over that you you spoke
about the themes of governance
um almost the need for categorization
especially when it comes to risk and
this categorization is a little bit
arbitrary because we're talking about
things which are very abstract and then
you have this problem a bit like good
heart's law that you know when you
um when you have a measure it kind of it
distorts everything because the measure
bit becomes the target
and
um what we want in in a governance
strategy is is to have an approach which
is intelligible
um not not so abstract as to be
ridiculous so how do you form that
categorization
I'm a big fan of thinking about the
production of risk so when you are you
might have heard of that time
long-termism right where people sort of
say oh they're suspect abide between
people who think about the short-term
problems of AI you know fairness buyers
and the long-term problems like AGI
that's the big and sexy thing that we
ought to be focusing on
if you're taking a different lens to
categorizing risk I think that
categorization itself breaks down quite
massively if you you know your interview
with Sarah hooker for example was a
brilliant case I think of of areas of AI
safety and Alignment that are labeled
under the time of fairness but
absolutely irrelevant to those kinds of
questions that are raised by the
alignment and safety Community right
which often gets separated out as
fairness is the boring bit that that we
would not focus on but what you're
noticing there is obviously that the way
that the risk is being produced in the
short term
um so a misclassification an unfair
treatment the problem of actually
fairness being a flexible
um construct that we have to adapt over
time which is a political question of
course right how do you bake that into
these algorithms all of these questions
arise in the short term so if you're
addressing them in the short term you're
also addressing the kind of risks that
are being produced in the long run of
the same types of Technologies so I'm
generally an advocate for sort of more
empirical approach to AR risk
um and then when you're thinking about
you know untrustworthy
algorithmic applications the way that
David Dangs for example talks about
um risk and AI which is much more
focused on you know we need to measure
trustworthiness as a sort of fine
um assessment of how well an algorithm
is actually structured and applied much
more focused on a particular context
rather than focusing on these broad
categories of AI you're focusing on a
particular set of tools in a particular
setting that are being applied to a
particular polish a group of people and
the solutions will differ from every
scenario to the next
um and I think these types of approaches
where you're looking at the production
of risk that is coming from the actual
setting in which it is produced so for
example in the case here where you have
particular companies that we have no
decision power over when they publish
something whether they publish the
source code
um what kind of applications they
published in the first place what kind
of data they use for it
there's a cool paper by leotard I think
2019 I think something slightly fuzzy
the title is something like we build AI
so what they were trying to show this
and actually be algorithm or the
component of the algorithm that are
really weighted heavily can be
constructed with the people that are
going to be not applying it themselves
but are using the application so in this
case it was an NGO I think that
um was hoping to optimize
um the way that they were sharing tasks
or so on right and so it was the the
task of the researcher to break down the
components of the algorithm that they
had hypothesize might be useful to that
particular task
to the stakeholders and they could
essentially vote by an interface of what
do I actually value about this procedure
and do I value how quickly I get to from
location A to B or do I value that
actually I do it in a particular part of
the day that you know I want to spend
time on this or something like that and
then you end up aggregating across the
people that are actually going to use
the application so what this was showing
that actually if you do the work well
you can translate the technical
knowledge into a language that is
totally understandable by the average
citizen by the person who gets to use
the the tool and I think that's the
burden here is on the person who wants
to develop that tool in the first place
and so when you're seeing citizens or
users not being trustworthy of a
technology in most cases is what you can
track it towards is that they're not
trusting the company behind it for very
good reason and in some other cases
they're very trustworthy trusting of the
actual technology so when you're looking
at the discussions of
algorithmic applications in China for
example which is often used as a sort of
example of a terrible surveillance State
um really problematic applications and
this is true there's great reporting on
this but what is also really interesting
to watch is where citizens are very
happy to use that kind of Technology
including facial recognition and so on
and I'm I'm just a fan of trying to put
that back into a nuanced discussion of
when exactly do I care about privacy
when do I want to give it up how do I
want that data to be controlled by whom
yeah do I want my library to so um
there's a
um there's a great book about it's
called burning the books um by the main
librarian here from from Oxford who
um was making the case actually if you
have an institution behind the data
collection that most people trust the
data collection itself is not the issue
it is very much again the political
institutional setting that makes all the
difference of whether the technology
ends up being positive or negative so I
really I really think that you know a
lot of the alignment or a lot of AR risk
is not about specifying that one
algorithm that codes ethics which sounds
to me like a very dangerous idea
but it is much more in AI governance
which is interesting more exciting space
to work in and you were speaking to
um an interface and a social contract
which I think is is fascinating but um
Igor what's your commentary on that yeah
I had wanted to just Cliff I would like
um I obviously agree with you and we
don't disagree just like would you
describe this with like real risk was
epistemic risk in this institutional
risk basically it's it just was there
before I'm not saying it's not something
to worry about it it is just something
that was there already just until now we
were kind of getting away with with
ignoring it and then the only other
photo that I would do is like what you
describe is like participatory
algorithmic design that's often in like
with the term sovereignty of it like if
you are involved in the design of his
algorithm like you kind of cite the
question of Ethics because you really
choose yes we want to be subjected to
this algorithm we consent by
co-designing and and we're not just leg
products which is kind of one of the
things that you also attached on that
leg if you are being tracked by
um meta or or Google's like
um ad serving algorithms then you're not
really consenting to that like even with
gdpr like you're not really consenting
to what they're doing it's just there's
a limit for how much you can deny and
deny them and if you put that back into
the process like when in by
incorporating that like Risk production
and giving you that sovereignty about
yes this risk I want to take because I
trust the actors involved in this risk I
don't want to take you resolve a lot of
issues without any technological um
solution it is really just like this um
accessibility asking for con consent and
like return of personal sovereignty in
these interactions
tell us about your position paper
you mean the the box article or yeah
um I mean this was just the invitation
to comment on the interaction between
FTX and the effect vulturesm Community
um
I guess what is interesting about it is
that he is a community that
Prides itself to
think about child risk obsessively right
think about optimization obsessively in
the dangers of good Hearts law
optimization and so on and it turns out
I think they
very much
um
very much made the mistake of of
I guess falling prey to the dangers of
optimization themselves and the bits
then actually we've already touched upon
that I find most generalizable about uh
this interaction
um is the epistemic risk Dimension right
the fact that you end up having a
misjudgment over the trustworthiness or
the accounting tools of your funder in
this case uh the FTX
organizations and and turn back I'm
afraid
um fine we make mistakes right we have
um misjudgments
that is not a problem if you are
in a decision making structure or
procedure an Institutional setting in
which the individual mistake
I guess the error right of the
individual encoding a problem and
spitting out a solution in this case you
know we go with FTX money
um gets washed out in a procedure that
is risk-averse and
um takes the minor differences between
people's you know diverse ways of
thinking about a problem and Aggregates
them in a way that actually the most
likely risk reducing policy right you're
never going to end this is a main issue
again with sort of ARS where you're
hoping to solve AR risk or alignment
that's not really a goal that we should
be focusing on because solving it to me
sounds like you're trying to get
something down to zero you're trying to
find the master algorithm that um you
know enshrines your version of Ethics
into law and uh into into code that's
very hard to change afterwards
um and I think that just sounds like a
power grab and control
but um really what we ought to be
thinking about is much less about the
specific outcomes that we're hoping to
Target and much more about a set of
procedures that give you a very likely
highly probable outcome for having
converged through that procedure
um on the policy that is risk reducing
right and you can think about risk
reduction from the perspective of the
organization so the uh brand of EA is
obviously tarnished in some ways now
that it has been associated with FTX so
that was just sort of strategically a
risky move to make to not check
um all the information that was
available at the time
um that they that they could have looked
at in order to protect their own brand
against it but there's a second
dimension which I find more concerning
which is the ambition behind the EA
Community or somebody call it altruism
Inc which is just the the points at the
Incorporation
social movement which at the time was a
social movement then a lot of money came
in and so it changed quite a lot but the
ambition here is nothing less but to
protect or do risk management for the
whole of humanity and the future of all
of our children and children's children
that is a massive task fine okay I
appreciate the ambition but what I don't
appreciate is um that you really then
ought to have very good reasons that um
you propose you are the one to be doing
risk management for everyone else right
you have to essentially show that your
epistemic procedure for converging on
the risk policies
are better than everyone else's so that
um we can entrust you with that risk
management strategy and I don't think
they have shown that at all
um and yeah this is I guess the the main
takeaway from from that article to say
really there has to be an Institutional
turn at the point where you're wanting
to take up that much uh responsibility
for that many people you have to have
shown that you're incorporating
um all of those different ways of
thinking about risk or what risk is
worth taking uh into account when when
you are doing your risk
um risk assessment right because risk is
so political and so value-based it is
not enough to Simply say we are striving
to reach Humanity's potential because
the idea of Humanity's potential carries
a lot of subtle ideas about values and
what is good in the world and what is
bad in the world right
um and you cannot gloss over that that's
so true um I mean Igor maybe you could
a quantify the damage to the effect of
altruism Community but but also um what
what Carl is saying here some would say
it reeks of paternalism Ivory Towers
gatekeeping
um what's your take
as in like what like she is accusing yay
of these things or the issues which is
pointing out uh well I I assume you
would be skeptical of a group of people
who think that they understand the
trajectory to a better Society better
than anyone else
um yeah I mean like the these are like a
dime a dozen and uh and
any like in my personal opinion anybody
who forecasts
um more uh than like a couple of months
in in advance in like a setting as large
as like Humanity without uh like having
a very precise definition of you like
what do you mean with Humanity for whom
are you forecasting and So like
um is just talking about out of the rear
end uh uh and and uh
I know a lot of very smart very nice
people in in the community who are
really trying at uh and who are doing
great work in very specific things
because if you if you narrow it down to
a much smaller scope you can do some
form of forecasting that's like we can't
forecast anything it's just on the scale
that that you're trying to do this
forecasting with all of the
um uncertainty involved in the in the
evolution of it
that's like
um truly like hopeless undertaking and
the response to that like if you can't
focus if you can't do a meaningful like
probability assessment about this that
you can trust is not to like try to get
the probabilities better like at like
you
there's different opinions on this but
my personal response to this is then
basically through like
not do any of this planning that relies
on forecasting and focus on what you can
meaningfully predict and hope that the
induction kind of occurs you through if
you fix
like big problems in the next 10 years
and you trust the like the future
Generations when they will also be nice
people who also want to like do good
things for the next 10 years like you
have sort of the long-term issue without
needing to think think about these
issues and you can't meaningfully do
like I said okay like how do we um act
today in a way that optimizes for in 10
000 years the only thing that you've
done is you have maybe given yourself a
bit of like leeway to ignore certain
things in in the current space where you
say ah you know my forecasting says that
this thing which is really bad for a
group of people which probably doesn't
include myself uh it justify is
Justified because it has this really
good outcome in a long time ago like
that's my biggest problem and like if
you want to act in a careful way and and
you want to try it you know like
um I think William S has a book like
more uncertainty like truly morally
uncertain is like mainly just minimize
your action to the absolute minimum if
you do act you kind of try to get the
people who you act upon on the table
respect to the sovereignty topic you ask
them hey do you consent to this and if
they can't consent for whatever reason
like you one of your first priorities
becomes like giving the ability to
consent and participating in that
because you might still it up but
at least you all it up together
and this is not a diffusion of
responsibility but is asking for consent
instead of just deciding because I'm the
best one either right to do this because
this is one thing where
um
like I think we agree on this but it's
like a slightly um different argument I
don't care how good somebody is at
forecasting they still don't have any
right to decide for me or could I touch
on that in particular so um there's
there's a spectrum of course on one side
we have anarchism and on the other side
we have authoritarianism and then you're
speaking to something interesting at the
beginning which is I mean if you take
the Islamic tradition for example it's
got error correction and robustness
built into it it's designed to kind of
like stay reasonably monolithic over
time and um is is that is is that
something to bring in there because you
are actually on the anarchist side of
things so you you don't really agree
with this paternalism yeah I'm always
careful to like labor myself as an
anarchist
um uh but what I what I can
um say Hello by anarchists have the
interest in critiques the uh the cons
the solutions are difficult to actually
find and Implement because they're
actually not doing any of the
simplifying assumptions that other kind
of like ideologies tend to do where
um if you're more of an authoritarian
leftist for for example then then you
have this idea of you need this like
Vanguard party or some form of like
state to kind of like
create this this wonderful Utopia which
we know how that ends basically and if
like if you are
I offer more like an aqua capitalist
persuasion and then like you have this I
believe it like private property which
implies a state and which is why most
like anarchists would say that because
it's not a real Anarchist
um kind of ideology
um but like this will fix things but
then you can ignore the fact that this
was the case in 1920s where like
especially if uh like really careful
boring reformist not at all
revolutionary anarchists which are
um like immigration of like Mario in in
the US like they at least point out on
the right issues and they try to do very
careful very deliberative a very
constants based um Solutions and I think
at least taking these uh like ideas more
seriously would probably help even just
for diversity of thought because as you
were talking about about like this
process of filtration I was reminded of
a paper I read years ago that looked
into the perception of uh
non-diverse groups versus diverse groups
of how creative and novel they were
being and how creative and novel they
actually were and you know as it turns
out if you if in a group of people who
are exactly like you you feel very at
ease talking about what you think is
like very bold and like edgy topics but
what actually doing is very like
expected of you whereas if you're in a
group of somebody who disagrees with you
heavily who checks you who contradicts
you you feel like you can't be as wild
and oh with an Innovative because you
actually have to like watch what you're
saying and nobody just hums along with
your assumption but for that challenging
process you actually make novel as a
Solutions and so so I think
we should take in the recent person but
we can probably also take from other
like political
um domains as long it is my personal
like political uh position so probably
there's something it can fit a
democratic and Equitable mold so any
ideology energy that kind of has built
in some idea of like I am better than
you therefore I get some for from
Authority
um I personally reject
yeah well so Kylie just just referring
us investment that's so interesting
we accept things which fall on our
abstraction manifold so things which are
intelligible and familiar to us and then
it raises the question of
um in the modern society we should have
a plurality of of abstraction and
concept and value manifolds right
yeah I I have to say this this term
right democratizing or Democratic sounds
so fuzzy it gets a bit of a bad rap it's
sort of as if there's um an ideology and
a political position baked into it and
yes that can be the case but if I'm just
looking at the intersection
of democracy and and risk like Risk
analysis to me sounds like a really
technical
um space where you're simply trying to
convert on that one policy that gives
you the most you know the most likely
um
an outcome that that was preferred by
the people that are taking the risk
together right and there I just think
that these Democratic or distributed or
participatory whatever fuzzy term you
want to put onto it take out all of the
politics it just is to me quite sensible
to expect that this will work better
simply because we have lots of different
agents that are encoding the problem
differently because of the different
brains and the different experiences and
the different settings in which they
reason and you're throwing that together
in a hopefully good uh aggregation
procedure and there's lots of details to
be figured out and there's again huge
literatures there landmwell is doing
great work Hong and page right very sort
of
um again in technical settings where you
can show that actually diverse groups
are outperforming the expert groups that
are simply less diverse even if they're
individually performing better uh deng's
uh Zolman they've done similar work
right where they can show the particular
settings in which we can prove this and
then we can have a look at the empirical
literature that it shows actually turns
out you know that often produces pretty
reasonable responses that now it gets
interesting sometimes of course the
experts the elites that have the phds
and that have the nice institutions
attached to their names they might
disagree with that that might not
necessarily mean that the conclusion
that the more diverse group converged on
is incorrect but of course it's
inconvenient I just I would love to hear
the argument for
you know what let's organize
um How We Roll Out AI for the rest of
humanity by essentially handling the
decision to a couple of people that are
sitting in a big philanthropic
organization that ended up there because
I don't know they were friends with
somebody in Silicon Valley right I mean
this is sort of how it works at the
moment and I think the burden is really
on on them to make a case for that that
is epistemically just the the best way
that we're actually going to converge on
a risk policy head that that makes any
sense right yeah the problem with um
diversity though is is it breeds
complexity
and um using intelligence tests for
example they're designed to make the
westerners look the smartest of them all
so um
we get back to this problem of
intelligibility which is to say if if we
have a plurality in in society I mean
maybe the ego you can
um you can take this but
um doesn't doesn't it it make the the
government significantly more um
unintelligible I would heavily disagree
with the idea of a diversity brings a
complexity of I think I think diversity
like unveils complexity is is so like to
be precisely like of course if you have
a system which is perfectly homogenous
there's like a single like type of of
person like oh like everything is the
same because there's like less complex
but that's not the world we live in like
like factually like people are quite
diverse people are quite complex and uh
like not to overquote people but like uh
yes there's this thing of um you should
make things as simple as possible but
not more simple so so like if you're
talking about like
a diverse group of people
you need to incorporate all of that
complexity if you want to have a
meaningful solution otherwise you're
just simplifying things at the cost of
somebody and to benefit somebody else
which is where this democratizing comes
in as well like democracy does not mean
vote by committee or rule by democracy
means you have a say in the process The
Sovereign
people kind of bulk everything I think
one big sentence that I have is that it
is being corporate to mean you can pay
for it which means
like this um
a quirk of a British system but like the
public schools are the ones that are
public to everybody who can who can who
can pay I think is like historically
grown I would think because they were
the first ones to actually do that like
that notion of democratic advertising of
if you pay for it you have you have
access is not what we mean when we say
democratizing what would mean is this
like Equitable access Direction and that
will bring diversity that will make your
decision making slower because you're
actually accounting for the complexity
inheritance system and and where things
are actually simple you don't add
complexity by asking a bunch of people
like what uh what you do is where you
need that complexity that Clarity you
will get it and where you don't actually
need it through the process you will
converge
because of the iteration for different
takes on it but like that pluralism will
like this is a bit of a strong state is
a statement but I think it will just
converge to a reasonable
um like consensus as we see it like in
Academia as well on things that are
actually very uncertain contentious you
can read a different way you get
different lines of research and on
things where somebody figures out like
the correct read on it that seems to
work
in all cases people like slowly
converged into that of course it doesn't
it takes time but we're talking about uh
like
a kind of long-term perspective right so
like that it takes
exactly it it it it allows you to like
make mistakes it makes sure that your
mistakes kind of wash out and it makes
the whole system more resilient which is
like one thing that when you talk about
like the the process like
if you have this concentrated power or
like these great capabilities
designing your system to become
self-defusing self-depowering putting
checks and balances in it's also a part
of this democracy definition that is
also like built-in risk management
management that like even if you get
somebody who is completely unsuitable
for a job or even if somebody does a
horrible decision it's not the only part
of a system that was kind of keeping
everything
together and that's something you get
for free with all of the ethics
resolving issues with all of uh kind of
um
efficiencies you also get from people
not chafing against your system and
trying to defend themselves against it
because you just solve this coordination
problem but like you said it comes with
some inconvenient things where in France
veyram's experiment with a citizen
assemblies and they got people from
Virginia who had previously like
protested against any form of carbon
taxes and they got them in the assembly
they had like an educational things to
inform everybody about the issues and
had debates and then like this I think
was like some trucker from a Britannia
who had been like on a fourth of
vegetation actually voted in favor of
very drastic Environmental Protection
that actually macro had to scale back
and kind of negotiate like we would like
to what we can't so like can we
negotiate
which like if if you
have this
Viewpoint that I sometimes here in
Academia when I discuss with people that
is this kind of negative view or that
some people just aren't able to like
look over or over the edge of their own
perspective or or CrossFit divide you
wouldn't expect and so it's like an
empirical falsification of that belief
that this type of radical
democratization couldn't work because
it's not a proof but in science we don't
do proof we do falsification well could
I put that to call it so um maybe maybe
the dmos are just a bunch of plebs
um I'm looking at brexit as as an
illustrative and instructive example
[Laughter]
oh no I mean it was tongue-in-cheek but
no my my I think Churchill was it who
said that um democracy is the least
worst form of government and cynically I
might just say that people vote in their
own self-interest
so whether it's a matter of
intelligibility or not does
self-interest not dominate
but in many cases I'm sure it doesn't
that would be a good thing right because
I think
um
if if you want to protect people from
risk which is the I guess the goal right
um then you need to listen to them of
what they consider to be a risk I.E a
bad outcome that they don't want to live
under and so voting and self-interest is
under that conception not a bad thing
but I obviously know what you mean I
would
um I'm obviously not a scholar of
democracy this is this is huge so
landamer has various books for example
where she goes through all of those
objections
um some of them are more theoretical
some of them practical what you end up
seeing is that obviously has a lot more
diversity in the way that people vote uh
most cases when
my sense now is that when we don't quiet
as you know well we we don't agree with
uh the voting outcome or so we probably
don't quite understand what the vote was
really about or so
um and
yeah I I think
I see a lot of the
obviously the these examples that ego is
bringing up are exactly the ones that
I'm thinking about where I actually
people under a specific setting very
much Converge on what we consider to be
useful outcomes
um let's say very measurable in respect
to climate politics right
um
but I think it is it is not on the
individual
um making a decision here it is very
much about the procedure that we put in
place right so I think this is an
argument that I'm also making in this
article which is you're not going to
find a solution by by trying to sort of
Cosplay a perfect Bayesian Reasoner it
is about Collective rationality and the
burden is on finding the procedures and
here AI comes in again finding
algorithmic tools software that can
allow particular procedures to manage
the complexity that you rightly point
out right things are becoming more slow
things are becoming more bureaucratic
these tools can help us reduce all of
those problems that we obviously see in
aggregating across a multi-agent system
when they all have different opinions
and ways of of proposing a solution
um and that is that is where I think the
work ought to be at the moment and when
we don't Converge on something it is
probably because this procedure that
Aggregates information puts in the
information that is actually accurate
rather than inaccurate misinformation
space again very interesting set of
tools there where actually the solutions
are not going to be in tagging fault
information correct information by some
instance right some board that decides
what it is or what isn't but it is much
more about creating an environment in
which people can reason best right not
having a feed that allows you to only
scan the titles of the articles but also
being enabled to do a sort of
crowdsource tagging which again uses the
collective reasoning abilities okay and
you said
um a kind of uh Collective
um reasoning
or Collective rationality with the term
you used and um I mean maybe Igor you
could comment on this but it to me this
evokes images of Game Theory and it
Ayan Rand comes to mind and Jesus you
know it and
um multiple utility functions and
um and and orthogonal uh you know moral
valence usually so um does that kind of
collective rationality work for you
eagle
um so just to quickly do the thing on
brexit yes brexit was a non-binding
referendum in a in in a voting system
where usually people do not get to have
have a direct say where the
parliamentary system that is the whole
justification of having indirect
democracy is that they will do the
responsible thing because they're part
of the elite and they if there's
something stupid happening they will say
no to that uh like that didn't happen in
this non-binding referendum so if
anything I would personally make the
argument that brexit was an argument for
like direct democracies because their
studies that in uh like policies where
they exist so like in California and in
Switzerland people actually do not vote
like in these like kind of impulsive uh
strategic ways to kind of like just a
safe frustration because they actually
use the fact that what they're saying
matters and it will probably be a bad
idea to kind of like tomorrow introduce
was like a Swiss style their democracy
in Britain but it would be a completely
different thing to say we commit to
introducing it in 30 years and I I
personally think like the incentive
structure for educational system when
like people who are in in the
decision-making positions for this oh
yes oh my God in 30 years whoever I'm
educating right now gets to run the
country and not just like in the elite
schools but also in in the in the ones
where like they're struggling for
funding for the cafeteria like that is
like a systemic shift in incentives that
I think would come come like very
quickly
um
the self-interest bit like the whole
non-democratic Foundation of our
currency which is like the market-based
like vote with your wallet thing relies
on the self-interest so we kind of as a
society have on both kind of sides of
like a divide I don't like with like
left versus right like economic
personally like I think these types of
sector are not really helpful but in
every like saying part of society that
I'm aware of self-in and self-interest
is at least more or less accepted as
something that isn't horrible even in
the micro level where in a good
relationship you need to draw your own
boundaries like if if you always hope on
your partner kind of guessing your needs
like it's not a good thing so it was
just direct reactions to that now on
your question on uh on like Collective
personality and Game Theory I think one
thing that
um is missing from like the modeling
here often and what like I mean I'm in a
game theory lap right now uh
great luck I I have to say
um but I'm not an expert in this but
through my readings I I haven't really
found anything that formalizes what we
really talk about which is like
negotiation and deliberation not
aggregation because there is a different
thing it is an interactive process
through yes there might be some form of
aggregation but you were also giving
feedback and you were expected to kind
of update yourself
getting better tools to speed up this
type of negotiation and Liberation and
sharing of perspectives so like the
whole system can converge to actually
what you like might formalize as a Nash
equilibrium or a course National like
some form of solution concept that we
consider being like a good thing to to
converge to and then we go with what we
went up there
I think that would be like a very
interesting like technical approach to
take to improve the political and and
the illegal process so this is where I'm
a bit sad that like
we also have to say like the alignment
crowd is a very tiny tiny tiny subset of
computer science and they are computer
scientists working on algorithmic
Mechanic design and Analysis like this
and Building Systems uh like this but if
you truly believe in the idea that um
something like a superintelligence might
occur and and you have to like design
like systems of incentives or or find
out ways to like create like ones that
are somehow
um in favor of all of humanity this big
uh then and I think this would be like
one of these um instances that I touched
on earlier with like you want to find
ways to that that work across
um service without putting a probability
on them you just find one that works and
whatever world you uh you end up in and
this would be one of them like using
Game Theory tools and AI tools as you
also touched on to
um improve this negotiation and this
remain increases to get this Collective
rationality actually unveiled
um even in cases like brexit for example
where the system might not be conducive
up purely those would be interesting
technical questions that go along with
our perspective of that the real risks
are not the technical ones I was just
going to bring it back full circle
because the this idea which often crops
up in the rationality crowd as well
right the less one community and so on
that
um right that the voter the average
person is full of biases and it's all
about trying to avoid those biases
umbrellas and others have done fantastic
work to show that a lot of the biases
that we see in human psychology
obviously have very good reasons for
being there because they're very adapted
to a particular environment and even the
current environments they make a lot of
sense right and you can read those
papers they're great but when we're
thinking about uh systems and
environments that aggregate those biases
together allow them to exchange
information through these deliberations
tools we can also think about the
complementary capacity that AI can bring
to this right surely there will be
spaces that no aggregation and
deliberation procedure can properly
cover and that is where we can
complement now with algorithmic tools
that yeah we can call them AI or AGI
they will be generally intelligent in
different ways and I think Chris is
making this argument right that there's
no reason to replicate humans we have a
lot of humans around let's try and find
a space where actually we are benefiting
from having a different kind of bias
which we have in these algorithms to
complement the kind of space that we
can't cover and that as a whole right
that human team uh human machine teaming
assessed as a whole agent then we can
call that super intelligent I'm happy
with that but and it will include a
bunch of risks that we want to deal with
but we want to deal with it as a police
right as a whole population of
politically minded people and that's
just what I would love to see in the
next couple of years amazing thank you
so much Carla and Igor closing statement
so what uh one thing that I would really
like to have home is like my personal
take on this like AI risk alignment risk
thing is that the framing of this is a
technical problem is extremely like
overblown and like the really careful
really competent researchers that like I
I me I meet and I have my in my lap
um like the most competent in my eyes
They Don't Really worry about the
technical side they see technical
problems to it to solve and like
um
my lab I wasn't biased like they have um
like work on robust AI safe AI like a
fairness and so on
um but these are like these small
incremental improvements that like we
have tools and to solve this when you
blow it up to a degree that is being
discussed in in the restaurant uh
alignment and so on crowd which all like
try to do the best and I think I'm
actually like happy that they exist and
they have like a different opinion than
me and they're taking this this Morse as
seriously but my critique is that they
really seem to buy into the hive that
this is something different and I
remember joining my lab and my Pi I
actually
um kind of being a bit easier in my
enthusiasm oh this is something
different and calling like deep neural
networks just multi-index models that is
like a very like like sober like still
like passionate take and like on working
with his stuff but it takes away this
kind of entrepromorphizing magic and
moves you from like this realm of like
thinking about science fiction risks
into actually operationalizable precise
risks that is like something that for me
is is missing in that particular thing
once you then like move from these
technical issues for political side
Carlos said everything and people should
like read her her position paper and
like just overall read what she what she
says it's like the final statement this
has been a wonderful discussion and
thank you both so much for joining us
I'm really looking forward to publishing
it um amazing yeah thank you
cool wonderful right brilliant